Hey there!
Nice of you to
check out this video on the AI Coffee Break
channel, that just surpassed 500 subscribers!
[party sounds]
Crazy!
Ms. Coffee Bean and me still cannot believe
it! This channel, that started first as a
creative and playful spin-off to my
semester of teaching in Corona mode,
now has so many subscribers, that
follow the content regularly!
This is 20 times as many people
than I have taught in one semester,
and on YouTube we can explain things to
the whole globe and do this even when
I am sleeping! because Ms. Coffee
Bean does the whole explaining.
Thank you all for joining
us in our humble beginnings.
Ms. Coffee Bean will do her best
not to disappoint you in the future!
Ok, enough of this, now we get
to the topic of today’s video:
This video is taking a breathing pause,
[breathing in and out]
after Ms. Coffee Bean is quite overwhelmed with
recent advances like GPT-3 in Machine Learning,
especially in natural language
processing or short NLP.
So if you feel a little overwhelmed too,
let’s take a top-down theoretical view on the
whole situation of data-driven language models.
In this video, we will address 3
important questions: What is meaning?
How far is state-of-the-art in NLP from meaning?
And: Do publications misuse the word meaning?
Especially, we are discussing the paper
of Emily Bender and Alexander Koller.
This is not only Ms. Coffee Beans
favorite paper of the month,
but it won the best theme paper award at ACL 2020
for the theme of the conference "Taking Stock
of Where We’ve Been and Where We’re Going".
Even though this video is about NLP,
we think there are important messages
that everyone in AI should think about.
The paper delivers theoretical considerations
about what a language model trained purely
on text completion can learn about meaning.
CB: What is meaning?
Well, wait for it, we will come to that later.
Now we ask: How often have you heard academic
publications, news or even Ms. Coffee Bean
say that large language models, especially
Transformer architectures like GPT-3 or BERT
“understand” natural language and learn “meaning”?
Far too often, to be honest.
And in Ms. Coffee Beans defense, she
also puts it like this from time to time,
trying to simplify things
and deliver messages quickly.
Otherwise, she is afraid she might
be spending too much time on defining
appropriate terms or opening a
philosophical discussion about
how far we are on the ladder towards
natural language “understanding”.
But now there is no more way around this.
It is time to discuss this with the help of
this paper and at least warn that words
like “meaning” and “understanding” can be
very easily misused and misinterpreted when we are
talking about language models like BERT or GPT-x.
And this leads to an undesirable mismatch
between what research tells it
does and what it really does.
So the authors write: “We argue
that the language modelling task,
because it only uses form as training data,
cannot in principle lead to learning of meaning.”
This is a very strong claim to accept,
especially if you have seen BERT
perform magic on biology data,
or seen GPT-3 translate, make copycat
analogies and many other things.
But wait a little, what does this claim
even mean? We will not be on the same page
until we have explained the terminology.
So it is time for the “terminology taser!”
It is very important to define what
a language model is. With “language
model” the authors (quote) “refer to any system
trained only on the task of string prediction,
whether it operates over characters, words or
sentences, and sequentially or not.” (end quote)
So BERT, predicting masked
words or tokens in sentences,
is definitely falling into the
category of a language model.
Now: What does meaning mean? Quote:
“We take (linguistic) meaning to be
the relation between a linguistic form
and communicative intent.” [buzz disk]
Wait, what? Have we just explained
a term with two other ones? Yeah,
but don’t worry, because we are
at the terminology bottom here!
To get away from the range of the terminology
taser, we will now build an example based on
Alice and Bob talking to each other: Alice is
hungry and she wants Bob to bring her food.
That is her communicative intent,
she wants him to get her food.
But for Bob to get the message, Alice needs
to realize her communicative intent into
a form, or into something in the real world.
This could be imperative air vibrations that
Bobs ears perceive as Alice’s commanding voice
“get me food!”, the trace of a pen on paper,
the pixels of this video, or the hands and the
face in signed languages. Now, for Bob to get
the message, he has to understand the meaning,
so he has to find out the right combination of
all possible pairs of expressions
and intents that Alice could have.
Notice that Bob does not have access to the
communicative intent, but only to the form.
Then, if he gets the right meaning
of the form without access to the
communicative intent, then he has
an understanding of the situation.
But he has to be careful, because the
meaning of Alice’s “Get me food” expression,
is not to be confused with
the many conventional meanings
to Alice’s expression: For example, she might
have said “Get me food” as a request for
something to eat, or she might just wanted
Bob to bring her their dog called “Food”.
“This is not a conventional meaning of
Food”, you might say. Well, keep in mind
that this is only the term for describing
all potential meanings of an expression.
The conventional meaning does not have to be
neither widely accepted, nor in any dictionary:
Think about you and your best friends
inventing words or using words as a code.
That meaning is in no dictionary, but
you both know what that utterance means.
But just imagine: The gap between form
and meaning is bigger than one thinks,
because the number of communicative intents
is huge. We as humans, cheat a little,
because we have access to the physical, social
or mental situation of our interlocutor.
But a language model, so a system that was
trained only on strings to do string completion,
does not. And while humans given a form,
try really hard to make a mental model of
the communicative intent of the interlocutor
and understand the meaning, a language model
never does: It gets the form and computes
similarities and likelihoods to other forms,
that have to be the right response, without
building a model of the communicative intent,
and this one is crucial in the
relation between form and meaning.
So the authors argue, that quote:
“the language modelling task,
because it only uses form as training data,
cannot in principle lead to learning of meaning.”
Yes, so what? GPT-3 is still performing
like it would know a lot about the world!
Well, it seems like quote “their apparent
ability to “reason” is sometimes a mirage
built on leveraging artifacts in the training
data (i.e. form, not meaning).” Endquote.
All that a language model has seen, is an
enormous amount of utterances about the world,
but it does not see clues for the communicative
intent and it also doesn’t try to model it.
To put it another way: would you expect a
child to learn what language means , if it
did not interact with the world at all, but hear
a recorded tape and trying to repeat the words?
To make this even more clear,
the authors propose an Octopus thought experiment.
Ms. Coffee Bean retells it now with minor
alterations: Once upon a later time,
we have again Alice and Bob, now separated on two
different islands, because Bob did not succeed in
bringing Alice food. But because they still miss
each other, they are sending messages to each
other through an underwater cable.
Only that Mr. O, this octopus here
is super intelligent and has tapped
into their communication line.
Of course, Mr. O does not speak English, but
over time he learns patterns and can predict
what Bob’s responses to Alice are and starts
sending messages to Alice instead of Bob.
Alice does not notice the exchange, since Mr.
O is getting really good at this impersonation.
He can even realize that some words are used in
similar contexts and can be exchanged if needed,
can construct whole plausible sentences. Only that
Mr. O has never seen the objects that Alice and
Bob are talking about. Because their communication
is kind of regular, this is enough for the while
when not much changes on Alice’s and Bob’s
islands. But one day, Alice says that she
invented a coconut catapult and sends the building
plan to Bob. Mr. O intercepts the message, but
can not rebuild the invention, because he
does not know what ropes or coconuts are.
But from earlier conversations, he noticed
that Bob would react very excited like this:
“Great job!” But did he really understand what
the coconut catapult is and what it is for?
No, he did not grasp the
communicative intent of Alice,
because he misses important
observations about her world.
Happy with Mr. O’s reply impersonating Bob, Alice
asks: “What should I use the coconut catapult for?
Should I use it for sending
you coconuts to your islands or
should I use it for defending against
the bear lurking in the bush?”
Well, Mr. O has a problem now, not knowing how to
respond. What is the friction coefficient of air,
how does gravity without the Archimedes
force works? How far are the islands apart?
How much does Bob want a coconut? He would
not even get this far with these questions,
because what is a coconut and what
is a catapult in the first place?
All he knows, is that coconuts are used in the
context of food and catapults in the context of
defending. But can coconuts defend against a
bear? Can coconuts fly from Island to island?
Mr. O had a great time impersonating Bob, but
now he has to admit his defeat. We hope that the
allegory of Mr. O was meant to clarify that
language models are in Mr. O’s situation.
So what to do? We have to keep in mind, that all
arguments so far hold only for language models,
so systems that are trained to
predict missing strings in a sequence.
We can also think about new tasks and
datasets that are augmented with meaning,
for example about those that try to
ground language in a visual situation.
For more on this, check out our video linked
right now and also in the description below.
Also, that a language model does not acquire
meaning, does not mean that BERT does not deliver
amazing results. This paper tries to set a
warning sign that reveals what meaning is,
how far state-of-the-art systems are from meaning
and how publications misuse the word meaning.
In a field where after GPT-2 comes
GPT-3 with even more impressive results
by only being trained on language
modelling, we have to take a break
to think about what the system let’s us
think it can do and what it can really do.
Because we did not address all aspect of the
paper, Ms. Coffee Bean really recommends you
read the paper yourself or even have
the authors read it out loud for you!
Links to the paper and to Soundcloud
are in the description below.
Let us know in the comments what you think!
This is kind of a controversial and upsetting
topic and it might need some time for digestion.
Thanks for watching patiently until the end!
See you next time!
Bye!